he used to play the drums he still does
play the drums too but he used to play
them more including with members of The
Black Crows
and they played with with members of Led
Zeppelin so he just says he's just like
one call sheet away from Led Zeppelin
everyone please welcome Ryan
all right hey guys I'm Ryan Klein I'm a
data scientist at Continental resources
in Oklahoma City uh we're an energy
company
um so right in the middle of the Tornado
Alley so feel free to come visit and let
that be an enticement
um so I uh
title my talk is using plumber to expose
malls in Excel so I know nobody bought a
ticket or traveled from who knows where
to come here about Excel but consider
this more of a gentle intro to the
plumber package that just happens to end
up in an Excel template
so first we're going to talk about a use
case that led to this discovery and then
we're gonna walk through kind of a live
demo so you know what could possibly go
wrong
um
use case Continental resources uh we're
a Energy company we have about 6 000
Wells that we operate which means we're
in charge of everything
um on average it's about eight million
dollars just to get things set up before
we see any kind of return on investment
that's 8 million give or take a couple
hundred thousand dollars in there
so
in my position I'm in I.T so I get to
work with people from all across our
company so there's accountants there's
guys in the field there's engineers
so again with eight million dollar
investment we want to make sure when we
set these Wells up they are the most
finely tuned things we can get because
it's a pretty big check to write with
nothing comes back on your investment so
working with our engineers
we developed a model that will say given
these parameters what can we
realistically expect to get back
give an awaken control now there's some
things
we can't control geology
um
things that you know just things that
we have no we can't turn any knobs on
but there's a lot of operating
parameters we can and of course with
those operating parameters comes the
cost per
whatever unit of measurement you want to
consider so
and there's other things like how close
is this well to another well what's the
optimal distance and spacing what order
should we finish these wells in all
those effect performance so working with
our petroleum Engineers we created this
awesome shiny R tool so
basically it's 50 input fields which is
a lot to hand enter so that's where you
see the awesome map there they can
select a well similar to where they
think this new one's going to be it'll
drop that data in they can go through
and manipulate a few things they can
tweak a few fields and it will spit out
a prediction
and so great cool awesome we love it but
after a while I go back and you know
follow up with the users and I find out
well what we're doing really is we're
running one of these we're putting it to
excel we're changing a few things
putting it to excel carry on to Ad
nauseam
so I thought okay well we can expand
this shiny R tool you know we can expand
grid we can put in a range of values
that can create new data do predictions
and they're like yeah that's cool but we
still want it in Excel
so all right we're going to meet the
user where they're at you know I'm not
going to try and
change the way they do business because
basically they said besides the mapping
feature which is cool we just want to be
able to select a well and
permutate it and get results back
so of course the answer to that
Excel yay
now I know there's a
there's an image that we can come
sometimes have of excel
um but this is not about the tool it's
just about getting the user what they
need so they can do their jobs and we
can all make money and go home at the
end of the day
and again everyone mostly everyone has
some sort of skills that Excel I know
mine were greatly diminished for a while
until I was forced to use Excel again
um and for lack of anything else it's
the most widely used bi tool in
existence even after AI destroys
everything and the Smoke Clears someone
will have an Excel sheet that the macro
stopped working on
bonus of excel is all the built-in
functionality right there's filtering
there's
stuff everyone knows what Excel can do
and again this is about not what I think
is right or best but slow walking the
users to something else so if they want
to use Excel for now we'll
give them something they can use
and the other benefit for our group is
once they get these permutated values
they can they do further financial
analysis they have to put together
submissions and everything else so this
is just a way for them to get a bunch of
results at One Clip and look through
them and find okay this return may be
best but it's going to cost the most and
we can do it for this much it may not
return as much maybe the life of the
well gets extended so all this lets them
use their tribal knowledge to further
these projects
and so the end result I ended up with
was this
very green and white spreadsheet that
has
all their fields in there so the top
left chart is the input fields and the
bottom right are we have about 13 14
outputs
along with an outlier score which I'll
get into here in a second so
the benefit is this upper left the
well-named search they can pick a will
they know their Wells enough because
they work in a specific area they can
pick a well similar to what they're
looking to do
it will go out to our warehouse pull the
data back they can copy it down how many
times they can go through and tweak one
field they can tweak two fields and I've
written it where it's Dynamic so they
can run
a hundred thousand iterations it might
take a weekend but they can run as many
as they want and get those results back
so we're going to actually jump into R
to talk about how I did this in plumber
and I am by no means an expert and
plumber but this should be a soft intro
enough or if you're interested you can
Google things
so
for this demo I found a data set out
there that is not pertinent to anything
it's the
2012-2013 house prices in Taiwan so if
anyone's interested in a half Bank Model
come see me after this and I'll make a
good deal but
so what I did I just ran a random Forest
on the data random Force regression
and
I saved that model off so this is
somewhere local
just for this conference if this was on
our Network it's safe somewhere else
where
if they're on our Network anywhere they
can access this this API call
so that's my model and it's built and
tidy model so you can use all the cool
functionality and tidy models and just
basically you're passing in this is your
new data you're passing to it to get
back results
now something I like to incorporate is
something Max talked about in last
year's conference is isolation Forest
as our users go through and change
values and change values they may get a
little
left of center on some of these
collections of values with 50 fields
there's you could get some very outlier
points but still get results and they
may look at that and go oh if we just do
this we're going to make x amount of
dollars but the model may not have been
trained on that so it's more
extrapolation than interpretation so
using this outlier score gives them an
idea of how trustworthy a the data set
is totally removed from your our Target
variables
so this is just running isolation forest
and then I actually
if anyone's unfamiliar basically the
higher the score the more outlier
extreme it is so what I do is I train
this against our entire data set
and I normalize it zero to one so the
use it makes more sense to the user if
it's closer to one it's more
iffy if it's closer to zero it's more
what the model has been trained on
so all of this information gets saved
out somewhere that this API can access
so once that's done that's the the
modeling part so here's the plumber file
if anyone's ever used plumber good if
you haven't then welcome friends I
haven't either till this so
creating a new plumber file it gives you
a nice template and it makes it pretty
easy to input what you need to input
so you get your API title which is
whatever this data set was called I
copied and pasted API description which
is a super accurate and well thought out
model for the r conference
and then here are the fields that we're
including this data set there's House
age there's the distance to the nearest
station there's a number of convenience
stores and latitude and longitude
so these are all the parameters I'm
worried about passing into this API
function is kind of what's the default
value if they don't if nothing gets
passed in what can we set there so
this is something you can handle on the
front end whether using you know Excel
or Tableau or power whatever you want
whatever your main interface is you
could do error handling on the front end
data data value validation on the front
end or try and catch it in here
so here's my note to add data
validations here I didn't get too far
into it
so I know when I pass in this data it's
going to be a big long string
concatenated together with a delimiter
of the pipe so as it comes in from the
API call I'm splitting it unlisting it
and then I'm actually making sure it's
the right data type so you could do
factors you just want to make sure that
whatever your model is trained on the
data comes in and gets converted to that
same type
so here it's just handling all those
values coming in
and then so they come in as individual
columns then I've unlist them and then
smush them back together
and that's the industry term is smushing
back together
and then lastly
I'm just using that it's my new data
frame right so that's what I'm
predicting on so model predict
it's that data it's the data has been
passed in it's been created so data
frame it's predicting it we're getting
the results
in that same right after that I'm using
that same data frame to get my outlier
score
which I'm also then normalizing to the
scale from zero to one so that it makes
more sense to the user because trying to
explain
outlier score to an engineer's
Time Will Smith
lastly I have my model output and I have
my outlier prediction and so those get
pasted together and then returned so
this is what API calls this it does all
this stuff and it returns basically a
single column in my case it's it's
delimited by my colon
now that's the whole function of this
plumber file at the bottom is where
it's actually reading in the model and
the data frame and anything else you you
can think of you want to use in your API
call
so here it's reading in the model the
outlier model and this is a data frame
that just has the min max scores from
the the uh isolation Forest so like we
can we can normalize them better
so now the plumber file is complete it's
ready to go
and so if you were just to come out here
and hit
run API and this here's the live demo
part starts
it will run it'll give you a a link and
every time you run this API it's going
to change this port
which is an issue if you have something
static like an Excel sheet because you
have to hard code in something
so there's a neat little piece of code
you can run you call your plumber file
and you just say this PR underscore Run
Port whatever number you want to pick
and that way every time this runs it's
going to be at the same port
so if something happens in your system
and things shut down and start back up
everything will still be pointed the
right direction
so at this point everything's ready to
go it's set up
we're ready to actually do something
cool with it so
here is my this is my fake Excel
template I'm doing just for this demo
obviously I'm a graphic designer because
this is a work of art but
so again I've made this where it's
it's variable in links so you don't have
to say you can have to do five records
10 records
to do that you have to do some VBA so
you know yay more programming but
there's a way to set this up where
again you can just feed it five records
ten records and hit a few buttons um
so just to show you how it works I'm
going to first kick off the plumber file
with my handy dandy little piece of
script here
and so this would be running somewhere
in our Network our system admin sets
this up and it's running and I never
have to see it again
so now I can come out and I can put in
whatever I want so let's say I'm worried
about a house age that's five years old
the distance the train is 100 there's
two convenience stores somewhere
and latitude longitude
you see I have a bunch of dummy data in
here so at this point if I hit run it's
taking this data passing it to that API
and returning the prediction
and the outlier score
now again you can go in and make it look
pretty and do whatever if you want to
this was just to get something out here
but maybe I'm curious about okay what if
it's five years old it's closer to the
train to inconvenience stores
so this allows them to quickly permutate
through these and you can see how the
prediction kind of changed and the
outlier score kind of changed
so this is a way for them to go in and
they can use all the drag and drop of
excel to change things they can put
formulas in they can do all that kind of
fun stuff
and they can run this fairly quickly and
get back results so again looking at the
outlier score like
0.61 is getting higher so that tells me
that this combination of fields
is something that the model hasn't seen
in our case either that tells our
Engineers that
this is not really physically feasible
or on the other hand it could be
something hey maybe this is some space
we need to go explore maybe we need to
run a test using these parameters to see
if there's
returns that we haven't ever thought
about before
so and then the other I guess benefit of
excel is that
you can add in whatever you want to to
make this a One-Stop shop for your users
these field names are
horribly shaded to kind of show
variables of importance so getting that
out of R is very easy so the darker the
color the more important that variable
is for this random force model so
distance to trains most important
latitude second longitude House age
think number convenience stores you
could add in any kind of chart you
wanted
you could do pdps you could put in shop
whatever you want to put in to help them
get more out of this tool
um
the other thing to add is on the back
end when I hit run it's going through
each of these columns and it's making
these named cells in Excel so this for
Excel specifically this is important
because
you have to have something that looks
like this when you set up your
connection you go to data queries and
connections
so basically you can see it's going
through
it's finding that name cell setting a
variable to it and then it's creating
this string down here this Source equals
json.document it's pasting all that
together and making the call so when it
comes back again it's a single field in
my case it has 14 colons in it these
other steps down here just split them
out make sure the the data types correct
it renames things and
spits it out into Excel so
that is the magic of using an API with
RF Excel of course there's a few gotchas
because there's always a gotcha
using power Query in Excel has a
character limit which I found the hard
way so depending how wide your data
frame is or how deep it is it's going to
hit the ceiling about 2000 characters in
that case I had to write
some more VBA yay code that would kind
of handle it in batches going down so it
would make a call for like 10 records
return it go down the next 10 return it
etc etc
and you want to make sure that your Port
is standardized like I said before so
that way if something shuts down it
opens back up
your Excel template will continue to
continue to run because it's pointed to
whatever you've set it to
so again this is not to say
you know hey everyone go do this in
Excel but hopefully this gives you an
idea how you can use plumber in API
calls to make this cool stuff you're
doing in art get it to the users
you know we can schedule jobs we can do
all that but for ad hoc
things like this this gives the power to
our users they can run it they can get
it out they can do whatever they want to
with it so
again I hope
this will give you some ideas going
forward if you have any questions come
find me afterwards I'll tell you what I
know
otherwise I appreciate everyone
listening and enjoy the conference
[Applause]